ce que vous voyez ce sont des immeubles
dont la construction a été stoppée en
Chine le secteur immobilier est en train
de s'effondrer et sans aide de l'État un
tiers des principaux promoteurs
immobiliers pourrai faire faillite
résultat les petits propriétaires qui
n'ont pas reçu les clés de leur
appartement sont descendu dans la rue au
risque de se faire arrêter et 1 million
d'entre eux ont décidé de ne plus
rembourser leurs emprunts cette crise
immobilière accompagne et accentue une
crise économique plus global en Chine
puisque ce secteur représente 25 % du
PIB mais alors comment la Chine en
Estelle arrivé là et est-ce que cette
crise économique chinoise peut devenir
une crise économique
mondiale depuis 30 ans les deux moteurs
de la croissance économique chinoise
sont d'un côté les exportations et de
l'autre l'immobilier et au cours de
cette période énormément de liquidité
ont été alloué à ce secteur les Chinois
ont investi massivement en emprintant
beaucoup d'argent il faut savoir que en
Chine placer son argent à banque n'a
jamais rapporté beaucoup que les chinois
sont entrepreneurs et aussi il y avait
un l'idée de se dire il vaut mieux
placer son argent dans la pierre c'est
plus tangible que d'avoir son argent qui
ge un compte en banque à la merci d'un
régime d'un pouvoir politique qui par le
passé peut prendre le contrôle
l'économie conséquence les prix se sont
envolé porté par la croissance ce qui a
créé une bulle économique au fil des ans
mais cette bulle est sur le point
d'éclater puisque trois mastodom de
l'immobilier chinois sont sur le point
de faire faite HMA country Garden et
evergande ça peut créer un
ralentissement de de l'activité parce
que ce sont des géants diversifiés qui
pèsent très très lourd et que le secteur
du bâtiment lui-même ça implique la
construction ça implique des circuits
financier donc la mise à l'arrêt de
certains de ces géants s'il y avait
vraiment une faillite ou ce qu'on retoue
le plus défaut de paiement c'est-à-dire
que ces géants ne puissent plus
rembourser leur leurs créances leurs
dettes vis-à-vis de des banques qui les
ont
financé il pourrait y avoir un vrai choc
en Chine la Chine fait face à une crise
immobilière mais pas seulement
subit également un fort ralentissement
économique si en 2010 sa croissance
atteignait 10,6 % en 2022 ce chiffre
chute à 3 %. cette année l'objectif est
d'atteindre la barre des 5 % mais ce tau
reste assez faible pour un pays comme la
Chine le pays va devoir s'habituer à une
croissance beaucoup moins élevée alors
que certaines régions sont encore en
développement si on prend toutes les
provinces du littoral chinois évidemment
ce sont des des provinces extrêmement
modernes avec des pb très important mais
dès qu'on entre plus dans les terres et
dès qu'on va vers vers l'ouest chinois
les les niveaux de de développement
économique chute drastiquement si vous
sortez des grandes métropoles plus
riches comme Shanghai
Shengen notamment au Rango et bien on
est encore dans un pays largement
sousdéveloppé avec un
système de santé par exemple rimentaire
autre enjeu auquel l'économie chinoise
doit faire face la hausse du taux de
chômage chez les jeunes urbains en Chine
21,3 % des 16 24 ans ne travaillent pas
et pourquoi parce qu'il y a 20 ans la
Chine a entamé la transition de son
modèle économique le but était de passer
d'un modèle basé sur l'exportation à un
modèle basé sur la consommation
intérieure et le problème c'est que
cette transition n'a pas eu lieu
aujourd'hui l'université chinoise forme
beaucoup de diplômés qui ont des des des
Master 2 mais qui ne trouve pas emploi
puisque le l'économie chinoise
aujourd'hui n'est pas suffisamment
mature pour absorber justement ces
emplois-là dans le secteur tertiire donc
en réalité la Chine a toujours besoin
d'ouvriers en nombre mais peu finalement
de jeunes diplômés
mais alors cette crise économique
peut-elle se propager comme la crise des
supres en 2008 qui avait commencé aux
États-Unis avant de toucher le reste du
monde la crise immobilière elle-même
selon les spécialistes ne ne comporte
pas de risque de contagion c'est-à-dire
que les financiers occidentaux
semble-t-il ne sont pas trop exposés
n'ont pas investi eux-mêmes trop dans
ces géants chinois et s'il y avait un
vraiment une chute de cesgéants on pense
que les grosses banques chinoises qui
sont pour la plupart publiques sont
soutenu par l'État de toute façon
viendrait à la rescous il n'y aurait pas
un effondrement avec des répercussions
mondiales comme ce fut le cas aux
États-Unis en 2008 si les risques de
propagation sont moindres certains
secteurs sont tout de même impactés
comme les producteurs de matières
premières étrangères les grands groupes
miniers qui fournissent du charbon et du
fer ressentent déjà le ralentissement
chinois par exemple le groupe australien
BHP a enregistré en juin ses profils les
plus faibles depuis la fin de la crise
du covid et ce parce que ses clients
chinois sont au ralenti mais qu'en
est-il de la France en 2022 la Chine a
exporté près de 78 milliards de
marchandises vers l'Hexagone du point de
vue macroéconomique si on garde le PIB
français ça resterait marginal parce que
même si les chiffres effectivement les
échanges se chiffrent en dizaines
milliards d'euros en terme de
pourcentage du du PIB ça reste
relativement modeste et encore une fois
on n'attend pas un effondrement total
des échanges on parle de ralentissement
pas d'effondrement c'est c'est quand
même toute la différence donc sil un
ralentissement effectivement il y aura
un impact sur certaines
entreprises françaises les plus exposées
mais mais il faut pas pour l'instant les
économistes sont plutôt
rassurants